please welcome back to the show someone
i absolutely love winnie harlow
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness a real audience wow
winnie was kind enough to
come to our show when we were in the
height of a pandemic and we talked about
going out one day and like doing
something we still haven't i know my
friends we've been cooped up for way too
long yes way way too long i definitely
need to
um be in the caribbean again and just
like party on the beach okay
are you i'll party anywhere with you i'm
going to jamaica i'll show you my island
although i feel like i want to go to
your new house will you tell me about it
so my new house is in california um i'm
really happy the selling point for me
was the palm tree in the backyard
look at this this is so amazing it's my
first house the first house i ever
bought and i bought it at 26 which i
never thought would ever happen
i can't think of anyone more deserving
but why did you not think that you would
get a house by 20
because i think when you're at a certain
age like you know coming out of high
school and you don't really know what
you want to do it's kind of difficult
you know everyone's kind of putting that
pressure on you like what are you gonna
do my dad was like all right go to the
army it's like a surefire way and i was
like that's not my portion in life i am
not going to go to the army and i
started getting you know these
opportunities to model
and i was like you know what i never
seen myself represented before and
being able to be that girl who you know
kids can see on the cover of a magazine
and i never got that experience is
really incredible to me and it's
empowering to me so i was like you know
what i'm going to continue this and it's
been very fruitful to me and i'm very
grateful
[Applause]
i mean
is it true
that you worked with beyonce
you know her did she take your boots
she did she did jack me of my favorite
boots once upon a time um i was on set
filming uh for lemonade oh which is the
most beautiful body of work ever yeah
100 so i was on set and they saw my
boots and they were like oh my gosh
where did you get those boots thinking i
got them from styling but they were my
own personal and they were like we need
them for beyonce and i was like
take my boots yep and i was like okay at
the end of the day like hey can i get my
boots back and they were like uh so for
continuity purposes we actually need
them for the rest of filming and i was
leaving that night so i was like okay
cool no problem they were just my
favorite boots but that's fine it's
beyonce and i walked into my trailer to
pack up my stuff and there were a brand
new pair of
way better boots so i i'll take it you
know i got to give beyonce a favor
i'm glad that you can both walk in each
other's shoes literally oh yes i never
thought about it that way i like that
i have walking beyonce's shoes
um well another pair of big shoes in
your house is your extraordinary
boyfriend um kyle kuzma
and he was uh an nba player for the
lakers and now he plays for the
washington wizards yep perfect
that must be fun
is it true that you are practicing skin
care with him teaching
games
guinea pig for all new products and he
loves it he honestly loves it he loves
having really good skin so i like just
like sitting him down in the bathroom
and just like doing his skin care making
sure that he's using his serums and
washing his face properly with
exfoliation but then also making sure
that he's protected from the sun with
spf you have to wear spf it's so
necessary like you want to protect your
skin before adding anything to it did
you learn that early i did because
having vitiligo and also being caribbean
one my skin is really sensitive to the
sun and i was always in the sun so it's
like a little
rock and a hard place sun care and spf
was always like a go-to for my family
and my family always always slather me
in it
[Music]